e quindi possiamo approfondire il
discorso che avevo iniziato l'altra
volta per chi non avesse visto il video
come investo i miei vi ha spiegato
insomma in che cosa investo quindi
andate a recuperarlo comunque in quel
video per farvi un riassuntino breve
breve ho parlato del fatto che io cerco
ho sempre cercato da quando ho degli
introiti di diversificare i miei
guadagni in modo tale da generare degli
interessi tra cui l'immobiliare le
cripto e tante altre cose insomma ho già
detto anche nell'altro video ve lo
ripeto anche qua non sono un consulente
finanziario wii non dovete prendere le
mie parole come legge vi spiego soltanto
quali sono i miei ragionamenti poi
ognuno fa quello che gli pare vi spiego
in modo un po più approfondito la
questione di che cosa ne penso delle
cripto valute perché né un discorso
veramente molto ampio io non mi ritengo
un esperto di cripto valute però nel
modo in cui lo recepito io era giusto
dedicarci un video tra l'altro in questo
video ci sarà il main sponsor che è blu
panda che una delle aziende fintec in
più rapida crescita in tutta europa con
più di 3 milioni di utenti ha senso
scegliere di panda proprio perché è
semplice e adatta a chi inizia un
percorso un investimento vi parla
permette di costruire un portafoglio
diversificato in cui si può scegliere
tra picco in cristo valutazioni
frazionate etf e metalli però di questa
[Musica]
mamma citate nelle un po più lontano sto
comunque di questo stavo dicendo
parleremo più avanti spiego un
pochettino che cosa ne penso io della
questione delle cripto valute perché
come vi ho spiegato appunto in quel
fatidico video di prima ho sempre avuto
questa idea della diversificazione
innanzitutto cosa vuol dire
diversificazione di assi ficazione
significa non investire in una sola cosa
ma in più ambiti in più cose diverse ad
esempio appunto l'immobiliare quindi io
100 euro e deciso di metterli 50 nell
immobiliare 50 in cripto è un esempio
quindi ci sono due modi per far fruttare
questi 100 euro che sono totalmente
differenti ogni cosa non è sicura e
quindi più diversifichi sostanzialmente
è meglio è questa la mia idea tra
l'altro nelle mie idee di verdi
diversificazione ci sono tantissimi
argomenti io non mi intendo di cripto ok
quindi non sono uno che si studia i
grafici cose mio cugino è molto bravo lo
fa io no infatti chiedo a lui non vi sto
a spiegare a bruxelles in tutte quelle
robe lì anche perché io sono una persona
che ha capito che cosa vuol dire ma non
è forse in grado di spiegarlo e mi
limito a spiegare in che modo recepito
sostanzialmente ci sta andando sempre di
più verso un mondo orientato su scritto
valute no io personalmente credo che un
domani possono avere un serio valore
delle cripto valute oggi già ce l'hanno
soprattutto il bitcoin parliamo del
bitcoin che è più semplice è cresciuto
proprio livello esponenziale ok il
discorso è proprio questo i bitcoin sono
limitati e quindi quando io ai tempi ho
sentito il fatto che i bitcoin sono
limitati ovvero che un giorno tra una
decina di anni finiranno quindi non
potranno più essere generati quindi chi
ce li ha se li ha e chi non ce li ha
ciao ho detto beh avere dei vip coin da
parte secondo me non è stupido perché
davy kho in un b coin è solo sta tanto
per ora per dire avere un qualcosa
investiti in bit coin non è male perché
se un giorno non ce ne saranno più chi
ce li sa bene chi non ce li ha se
attacca quindi teoricamente potrebbero
avere teoricamente poi non si sa è
ovviamente però potrebbero avere un
valore in crescita esponenziale quindi
oggi valgono tanto ma un domani
soprattutto quando smetteranno di essere
generati potranno valere
ma tantissimo c'è proprio molto molto di
più di adesso tantissimo di più e quindi
ho deciso di investire una minima parte
in realtà rispetto all immobiliare
quindi io tendo tendo a investire su un
po più sicure però una parte comunque o
investita anche in bitcoin in modo tale
che cielo lì e non voglio farci
speculazione sola dopo e magari li
perderò perché magari poi un domani non
verrà più un cacchio questo non lo
possiamo sapere ma potrà valere anche
tanto diversificato e quindi un qualcosa
l'ho messo anche la mini è stato il mio
investimento forse più piccolo tra tutti
quelli che ho fatto e questa è la mia
idea non voglio fare speculazione perché
non mi definisco uno di quelli che vuole
fare soldi in breve termine tac
raddoppio è nono del wall street ho
messo qualcosa lì da parte che so che
c'è comunque passiamo al discorso dello
sponsor di ojika appunto bit panda con i
panda ragazzi si possono fare tanti tipi
di investimenti ad esempio anche quelli
che vi ho elencato rispetto alle clip è
tutto a partire da un euro ed è una
piattaforma sicura perché appunto
regolata all'interno dell'unico europea
con le ultime normative e all'interno si
trovano un migliaio di asset tra cui
come vi ho appunto detto il decreto del
momento tra cui il bitcoin è tutto il
resto oppure i metalli preziosi di etf
le azioni frazionato un sacco di cose si
paga si fonda su tre grandi pilastri che
sono la prima e la completezza per il
fatto che da gennaio sono disponibili
oltre mille risorse subito panda
rendendola una piattaforma di
investimento a 360 gradi poi è una
piattaforma per tutti ovvero adatta sia
più esperti che ai neofiti se siete
degli esperti potete utilizzare infatti
anche b panda pro e infine ovviamente la
sicurezza perché è fondamentale quando
si parla di investimenti la piattaforma
offre una sicurezza all'avanguardia per
proteggere il vostro account e mantenere
il vostro investimento al sicuro se non
siete molto esperti di cripto valute
appunto anche di panda offrendo indici
che sono dei panieri per poter investire
punti in bitcoin per le persone un po
meno esperte ci sono attivi panda
savings che sono appunto dei piani di
investimento automatici all'interno
della piattaforma che appunto hanno
delle strategie di investimento in modo
automatico all'interno della piattaforma
su diverse appunto risorse in modo
ricorrente è infine banda stoxx dove si
può investire in qualsiasi compagnia del
momento a partire da un solo euro in
tutto questo ci si può anche munire di
carta ufficiale di bit panda insomma ci
sono un sacco di features in descrizione
il link per iscrivervi se volete dove
avete anche 10 euro di bonus in bitcoin
spiegato un po cosa ne penso del mondo
delle cripto ripeto ancora una volta
questi sono miei ragionamenti e mie idee
non sono un consulente finanziario e
quello che io
penso del mondo delle flip degli
investimenti in generale però ognuno
insomma alle proprie idee e fa quello
che vuole questo è quello che penso io e
quindi ragazzi spero che video vi sia
piaciuto fatemi sapere cosa ne pensate
appunto nei commenti insomma questo
mondo grande non parlo di n effetti non
mi sono neanche bene informato
sostanzialmente land effetti nemmeno io
ma perché non è un mondo che in realtà
adesso poi non so in futuro ma adesso
non è che mi interessi
particolarmente ve lo sto dicendo perché
probabilmente qualcuno mi chieda nei
commenti ma cosa ne pensi delle delle in
effetti in tutto comunque bisogna stare
attenti anche in quello quindi però che
i video vi sia piaciuto iscrivetevi al
canale lasciato un bel commento è un mi
piace fatemi sapere cosa ne pensate
questo non è in effetti comunque prima o
poi lo scanner izzo e faccio le
effettive del telecomando dai ragazzi
[Musica]